a thousand schools in Australia are
feeding children Cricket products and
their eating bugs already in Australia
Australia is one of the governments that
have has been pushing a lot of these
policies forward more than any other
government out there especially when it
came to their coveted policies
especially now when it comes to their
climate policies and before all of this
their policies restricting people's
ability to be able to defend themselves
and also have firearms so they are on
the precipice they had they have the
most amount of of young leaders coming
from the world economic Forum
influencing their government and their
government is literally talking about
implementing a central bank digital
currency they have they have they have
already set up literally quarantine
camps inside of their country that they
spent 580 million dollars building that
only housed sorry imprisoned
2168 people according to Rebel news
that's account for nearly a quarter
million dollars per guest during the
covid uh did you say a thousand kids a
thousand schools a thousand schools
spectator Australia a thousand
Australian schools are fed insects you
will eat the bugs you will live in the
Pod you will own nothing and you will be
happy yeah we laugh about this we make
jokes about this but this is a reality
in a lot of places around the world
where this agenda is already moving
forward uh in many deceivious ways under
the guise of of helping people that's
not helping people there's a there's a
lot of controversy especially when it
comes to the nutritional value
especially when it comes to the larger
physical effects that people have when
they do eat bugs a lot of people don't
like to talk about this but the science
a lot of it is bunk a lot of it is of
course financed by individuals like Bill
Gates that haven't invested interest in
pushing this and and why do they watch
any bugs so bad well they're making
because they understand that that if a
person is healthy they're not as
dependent as of course the person who is
unhealthy and I think there's a big
agenda to make people unhealthy and I
think this is why there's such a war
against meat what a lot of these people
who call for this this kind of
Singularity who call for this fourth
Industrial Revolution a lot of what they
have in common and is also their bigger
fight against meat meat one of the most
you know nutritiously densed food out
there you take away meat from the
general public as Bill Gates says he
wants Western Society to be completely
meatless in the next few years when you
take away people's nutrition you take
away their ability for for them to be
strong and to resist the larger takeover
of humanity which is happening right now
Bill Gates is not uh the image of health
absolutely not oh yeah he has members
he's talking about man have you seen
that new corn video have you seen the
new Corner oh I've seen it you haven't
seen the porn video of course I've seen
it oh he's looking pretty fit
he's I think I think he's he's obese I
don't know if he's morbidly obese but
he's obese he's good he's big yeah he's
oh he's a he's a big fella you know that
Bill Gates he's sad you got one job Bill
be be the uh the version of what you
want to see in people no this is what
it's going to be you're going to be
eating bugs while morbidly obese Bill
Gates has got a mutton Chopper or was a
what is it mutton is that the big lag or
whatever yeah and it's gonna be like
eat your crickets is there any way to
Ally with the Borg and come out better
for it no no it assimilates you're just
looking out for yourself Ian this is
like screw you guys like plug me into
the Matrix let me taste that juicy steak
in the metaverse is that what you're
like I feel like it's inevitably
happening like where it's the Avalanches
cascading we're riding it down the cliff
right now towards the everyone people
plugging in whether you want to or not
that Society will and then we'll either
you'll become dangerous to society if
you're not in it or you'll be forced to
because you can't compete in the job
market and you start to starve unless
you get it but like if you're in there
like I think Captain Captain Jean-Luc
Picard got assimilated by the borgon
somehow from within the network was able
to twist it but I could be wrong about
that no no he was he was in and they had
to break him out like there's no the
Borg assimilates everything in its path
I don't think there's obviously you
could you could create like some sort of
Trojan from inside the system but
look at this picture let's just be wrong
I could be wrong that it's that it's an
avalanche in process but what do you get
that Vibe like this this is what you're
fighting for I think that they're moving
in that direction and that no matter
what happens politically there will be
certain organizations that continue this
work right I don't think you're going to
be able to get rid of all of it okay but
at the same time
I think that they vastly overestimate
how much they're going to be able to
control the general populace meanwhile
empowering themselves with the real
technology right once technology goes
public and people have their hands on it
that's when the real Innovations always
begin right and that's where you have
the true Maverick so I'm hoping that as
this stuff rolls out it's the
underground that utilizes it to empower
Humanity instead of enslave us just like
a hammer can build a house it can bash
someone's head in and they're trying to
bash their heads in well look at look at
this remember everybody this is what
you're fighting for that's right that's
mutton
is that Rosemary on top that's Rosemary
Rosemary wow put some beef liver have
you guys seen it okay he's gonna be
sitting there holding the bone and just
tearing up meat while you're on the
ground in a potato sack wearing a potato
sack and you're gonna have a bowl of
crickets and you're gonna be like thank
you master and he's gonna back get out
of my side so that's the world they want
so if you haven't seen upload okay oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah have you seen it
Hulu or something it's on Amazon on yeah
Amazon but it is this idea that you
don't have to worry about dying anymore
that you are going to upload your
Consciousness and you know not to give
away too much of the plot but that's
what they want for the plebian class and
the plebian class is eating the printed
foods and the plebian class is living in
small apartments like your dorm so in
other words you're on these dating apps
but they're not dating apps they're pure
hookup apps everything's everything's
recorded so your Sexes recorded
everything and you're having sex next to
your roommate right and they just have
like a VR helmet so they're not paying
attention you're in like a 4x4 room
you're going on dates where your food's
printed and then you get to the people
that are running the show
and they have chicken and they have
steak and they're not driving the
automated vehicles that are this big and
they're not in the small apartments
humans when the rich people die they get
uploaded to like the Estates where it's
like this luxurious afterlife and poor
people have pay as you go where they're
in like the sterile white box and if you
talk too much you're burning through
data and then you just get Frozen when
you run out and someone's got to re-up
you so you just Zonk out and then you
come to a month later when someone
finally pays the bill to turn you back
on
or you got to fill out the Excel sheets
and do all the lame paperwork for all
the ruling leads you know it even has a
voting aspect to it so you know one of
the running themes is somebody who's you
know already uploaded themselves and
then can leave that Universe through one
of these entities or robots that they
build yeah that you've seen it
um and they talk about how the reason
they're doing this and they're offering
a free upload like he said most of these
are monetized and there are certain
tiers but there's this place you can go
to now that's kind of like this utopian
upload and like people are getting in
line and bringing their babies with them
because it's their only chance and once
you upload you're dead see that's the
kind of running joke it it takes your
entire head off right but one of the
reasons that there they bought this
infrastructure and bringing people into
it is because they want to change the
voting uh Records so basically they want
certain candidates in and they want to
get rid of the class of people that
would vote against those candidates
dystopic twist the people that are
eating the chicken and the lamb while
the plebs are all in their cars are also
going to be eating human meat because
what you said they're cut them off at
the neck they keep the brain alive so
that the person doesn't know that
they're just a rain but they take the
bodies for consumption
people are gonna have to eat people
they're not going to happen people are
going to have nobody's gonna have to do
it
you're saying they want once they get
the taste it's gonna be like oh this is
perfect and it's population reduction oh
man that's a little too much for me yeah
but that's why we got to make a movie
about it first you may just want to
bring up a cannibal story it's so
bizarre I don't even know if I should
we're we're going off the deep end we
got to save something for the members I
mean do you guys know about this Utah
case at all what Utah case so there's a
case out in Utah right now that is into
ritualistic child abuse okay and
apparently there was an investigation
that happened in the 80s and the 90s
that was thrown out of court
it was revamped this year during an
election year to the point where a
person named David Levitt went on public
television and said
I don't abuse children and I'm not a
cannibal these are all lies and you're
like taken back whoa what's going on
here
and basically if you reread this case he
was named with a group of other people
into some really like Texas Chainsaw
Massacre type stuff on children the
stuff that you couldn't believe
well one of his associates got arrested
this week named David Hamblin and David
Hamblin got arrested for hypnotizing and
sexually abusing children while taping
them at the six and seven year old range
and this is in that same time period And
they also arrested another person in law
enforcement in Utah that may or may not
be connected now these people are being
held without bond or bail either and
Levitt lost his election he was I think
a Utah County prosecutor and many people
believe that he's going to be the next
to be arrested once his term is actually
up and they're waiting for that because
he already knew these guys and he knew
he was the one being investigated now
when these kind of stories come out I'm
just like taken aback because I don't
know one way or another but the children
seem to obviously be abused they have
the physical evidence that they were and
they have a bunch of eyewitness uh
testimonies so it's interesting thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live to tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there